vagyok-e az aki merem vállalni a
valódiságomat nekik valódi felnőttekre
van szükségük nem tökéletes felnőttekre
és ha csak a szerepeinken keresztül
mutatjuk be magunkat és nem mutatjuk be
azt hogy de én ember vagyok akkor
valahol csak azzal van összetalálkozás
hogy a szerep számít a tanulmány a
teljesítmény és itt egy picit a szerepek
alatt kiemelném azt hogy a teljesítményt
is értem tehát nincs ahogy most értsó
nem a családapa vagyok és akkor én hogy
teljesítek hanem van amikor szerepbem
merevedések vannak hogy én vagyok a
mérnök és minden arról szól hogy én
vagyok a mérnök és semmi baj ha vannak
részek szegmensek amik szólnak arról
mert az gyönyörű hogy ő mérnök de amikor
minden a körül forog hogy én mérnök
vagyok és azon kívül hogy mérnök még
kicsoda